[Music]
imagine 91 billion light years traveled
I literally just got a chance to check
out the little teaser wrinkle in time it
looks incredible congratulations on that
and the reception up there people are
very excited about this a good friend of
mine is this kind of this gruff gritty
guy and when I told him I was doing a
wrinkle in time he nearly cried because
he said was the first book he'd ever
read but I didn't know it myself and so
yeah the reaction was was kind of
exciting yeah
working with Oprah Winfrey what was it
like working with her I loved working
with Oprah I I don't know what I liked
more talking about books or or acting
alongside her she's a man she's a force
of nature and there's a lot to be
learned from a woman who's made this
kind of impact culturally and in the
business and you see why there's pretty
much nobody better to talk books with
probably than no problem I mean best
just throning recommendations all over
the place I got I got a list 15 strong
with Oprah Rex just say really quickly
obviously with the success of Wonder
Woman everybody out there on the
internet trying to figure out a way that
you could show up in the sequel yeah are
you part of that campaign at all you're
trying to come up with any ideas
I'm an actor man I'm about as lazy as
they come so I'll I'll be by my phone or
somewhere so they can search they can
find me whenever they give me the call
easy ways flashbacks but I mean could
you have survived the blast I don't know
I guess you'll have to wait and find out
uncle too yeah exactly right yeah
[Music]
you